I believe that desire to create is in us
all the desire to leave our mark on the
world and bring something into it that
would not exist if we did not exist to
have a little piece of reality that we
created and to leave it as something
that might live on and matter beyond us
in regards to artistic creations to make
something that might matter is to create
something that is honest and unique
something that is at least slightly
different from anything anyone else has
ever done to say something that no one
else would ever quite say in a way that
no one else could ever quite say it to
tie the creation around the artists
personal thoughts and sense of life in
order to do this an artist must be
willing to face him or herself with
complete candor
they must be willing to face any
personal demons that they would
otherwise prefer to pretend don't exist
to travel into the depths of their mind
and to retrieve a part of themselves
that is potentially scary or sad
something that might be convoluted or
hard to explain something that is
perhaps counter to cultural norms and is
vulnerable or strange and then in spite
of all of this they must still share it
in this act the artists risks something
we all dread rejection worse yet
rejection on a very deep and personal
level and this is often where a problem
with self-doubt can arise in the
creative process caused by the fear of
rejection we can convince ourselves that
we should perhaps refrain from sharing
too much or being too self reflexive
that perhaps we are not deserving of our
perspective style or opinion that
perhaps we are wrong in feeling or
thinking a certain way and that we
should not create something that reveals
it because what if others don't agree
what if others don't like it
and if the piece is so closely tied to
our identity then they would also be
rejecting us as a person and our fears
would be affirmed but it is in these
moments that we must power through it is
in these moments that we must create and
share the very thing we are considering
turning away from if you wish to truly
create something that might matter
something that might make others feel
less alone in what they themselves may
be scared to share something that might
make others think in an interesting new
way and something that might leave a
lasting ripple on reality must be
willing to face and overcome the fear of
rejection and criticism you must be
willing to invest the necessary amount
of time thought and personality into the
creation of something and then risk
being told that it isn't good that it's
a waste that you're Nighy out of touch
unskilled dumb or any other demeaning
adjectives because it is often the
things that risk being accused of such
adjectives that people are afraid to say
or do but the things that people will
appreciate and value when someone does
no matter what we say or do in life
there will always be people who feel
differently or have something negative
to say people whose unique life
experiences don't mesh with ours but
that is the beauty of it there is
balance to everything if other people's
perspectives matter your perspective
matters too if you have been alive for
any amount of time your take on this
world is valid and worthwhile do not be
ashamed of it share it in any way you
see fit and stand by your creations even
if they make you cringe or feel like an
imposter believe in them and believe in
your potential if anyone is worthy you
are also worthy
that is not to say that you should not
take constructive criticism for what it
is worth and always be improving your
craft but it is to say that you should
always maintain the foundation of your
work in honest self-expression always
keep the roots firmly in your truth and
don't let anything scare you away from
that because if the fear of being
rejected by others prevents you from
exploring and sharing your true self you
are actually rejecting yourself and
there is no worse rejection than that
[Music]
thank you for watching if we found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
Channel
we are constantly coming out with new
videos to help you experience life with
clarity and Wonder